[Music]
here he is my famous brother Jackie
Burke now the kids kid we have one kid
she's an adult now she's getting married
I thought she was a day you say lesbian
possible game what do I have to do a
children's birthday party do you want a
job you want to be an S do I have to
choose let's talk about this apportion
of a town you live in
how many hours did you get long me too
my dad used to love your TV show we've
watched every episode always nice to
meet a fan
well we just had the one TV just a bunch
of hours Hey look are you free tonight
what like a date or it'll be just an
appointment I'm not sleeping with you I
don't know what you're after
look you had a terrible day you just
said it let me take you to a place you
might have a nice time celebrities bring
their hookers to the everything I've
done for you I was there for you when
you were starting out as a young man was
amazing I feel like I'm high do you come
up without that on the spot sometimes
yeah that was good are you free of
something I have a wedding to go to my
niece's wedding you could be my wingman
we have a few laughs we don't want it to
become anything it's an honor being here
to celebrate Brittany and Frankie's
wedding can i address the 800-pound
gorilla in the room flow what have you
done to my poor little brother he was
six feet tall
when you got married this lowlife
brother of yours I don't know why you're
yelling at him who are you we do not
want to wear dress I know what your
expectations are here my expectations
when you look at my daughter and the way
she's looking at you I'm not looking at
him what are you talking about we have
three offers for appearances what's
gonna be come on did Big Show they want
you
you're a dancer yeah come sit on my lap
I'll spin you around like a dream your
viral again over three million views and
eight hours and it is still climate you
are on Kimmel you're on Fallon ladies
and gentlemen Jacki Burke
[Applause]